[Music]
how's gonna rebates it's Lord macho
milords who gave me dotnet I'm here to
show you the PR manager for tollgate
productions how you doing shouting now
we're here to talk about rising hell
let's talk about this game so rising
hell is a arcade action game it's a
roguelike game actually so in this game
you climb out from hell
it's like down well but reverse reverse
down well with house alright alright
well one of the things that immediately
caught my eye about this game is a
visual appeal and the music the music's
just off the wall heavy metal so talk a
little about that and in this version
behind the music that's driving the
gameplay Oh actually the composer he
didn't even what is it he didn't see the
gameplay at all he just came he didn't
play any instrument at all so when he
signed for this game as a composer he he
learned from the scratch and then yeah
he mishit this you heard her first here
in Lords of game Annette so we talked a
little about the game that's like you
see some gameplay of rising hell so talk
a little about the level design here
that the players going through so in
this level
it's more of a beginner level yeah yeah
it's the first realm so you may be fine
what is it underlings my demons and
stuff that you the natural things you
see in Hell perfect so I had this being
the action-platformer and it's all about
verticality what kind of really kind of
abilities that players are going to get
in the game power-ups and we call it
relics so they can shoot lasers and then
also they'll have like kind of like a
sabre thing and then a lightning strike
some kind of like that that's cool yeah
no that's awesome that's awesome so with
all those power-ups that you're getting
haven't you taught the game there's
gonna be boss fights
how are the boss fights the boss fight
is a one bus have like three two or
three stages so also the multi-faceted
then not stages what is it like
transitions and different okay okay okay
perfect
so with the rising he'll do you know how
many actual levels have been made or
like around there there are three realms
for now yeah
with different levels and also we can
also choose like there's an elevators we
can choose like a random level so maybe
there's a one with so many traps and
then the other one you you get chased by
a fire by flames there's a lot of
personality within kind of the levels
and and and split something that players
won't expect yeah you did tell that the
game is in early access but when do you
plan on finishing production for a
rising health maybe this year sure for
certain lastly platforms where can we
play this amazing game it's on Steam
right now if you have any plans for
switch ps4 Xbox one well no doubt that
this game is gonna reach a big audience
it looks beautiful it looks like four
more plays even better and the music is
on point so I cannot wait to play thanks
so much for your time Sally but thanks
so much for talking productions here is
Lord of March the storm entrepreneurs
gave me that net thing that's for tuning
in
[Music]